Lisa Loring who played the first
live-action Wednesday Adams in the 1960s
sitcom incarnation of The Adams Family
has passed away according to deadline
the actor was 64 at the time of her
death on January 28 2023. the star
passed away at Providence St Joseph
Medical Center in Burbank California and
is survived by her two daughters and two
grandchildren the news of loring's
passing and her cause of death were
revealed in a Facebook statement by the
actor's friend Lori Jacobson it is with
great sadness that I report the death of
our friend Lisa Loring four days ago she
suffered a massive stroke brought on by
smoking and high blood pressure she had
been on life support for three days
yesterday her family made the difficult
decision to remove it and she passed
last night the success of Netflix is
Wednesday which has been renewed for
another season has recently returned
loring's most famous character to the
Limelight Loring was also known for her
role as Cricket Montgomery in the CBS
daytime drama as the world's turns
Loring burst on the scene in 1964 4 as
Wednesday Adams portraying the role in
64 episodes of The Adams Family until
1966 in 1977 she reprized the role in
the TV movie Halloween with the new
Adams Family the character turned out to
be an enduring one
playing Chinese water torture nice game
after Loring set the bar with her
performance Christina Ricci took over
and Barry's Son and feld's The Addams
Family movies and Nicole fuger inherited
the role in 1998's Adams Family Reunion
most recently the torch was passed to
Jenna Ortega for 2022's Wednesday
Netflix series outside of The Addams
Family Lisa loring's personal and
professional life was rather turbulent
she was married four times and each
Union ended in a divorce for a time she
also struggled with addiction issues
while loring's later work never quite
reached the heights of her iconic sitcom
role she remembered her times in The
Adams Family fondly indeed she remained
close with Gomez Adams actor John Aston
for decades after the show is over
Loring said in an interview view with
the nerd soapbox at the 2017 monster
palooza convention it was like a real
family you couldn't have picked a better
cast and crew as the first actor playing
what's become one of the more enduring
and iconic comedy characters out there
Loring was very much a Trailblazer as
such people in the entertainment
industry have been quick to react after
learning of her passing journalist and
author Dan Savage tweeted not the
obituary I wanted to read today former
NBC Universal senior executive Mike
shington and actor Morgan Fairchild also
noted the sad news while Mark Hamill
summed up his feelings with a simple
heartbreak Emoji meanwhile actor Barbara
Crampton had a longer message for the
dearly departed luring posting R.I.P
Dear Lisa Loring delightful in the role
of the youngest member of The Adams
Family your iconic presence as the
original Wednesday will forever be
remembered you are an important part of
our cultural history I was so happy I
met you I hope you knew how much we
loved you and Lauren's friend Lori
Jacobson ended her Facebook post with a
sweet message posting beautiful kind a
loving mother Lisa's Legacy in the world
of entertainment is huge and the Legacy
for her family and friends a wealth of
humor affection and love will Long play
in our memories R.I.P Lisa damn girl you
are a ton of fun
[Music]